[Music]
pastor mark the question is the two
witnesses in revelation who are they
okay that's revelation chapter 11. two
witnesses and it's that's a very good
question
and let's go to revelation 11
and
answer the question right directly from
the bible we don't have to guess at some
of these things because the bible does
explain itself
so it says
in revelation chapter 11 um let's go
back and i'll pick up and i'll start
with um
verse
and i will give power to my two
witnesses and they will prophesy
1260 days clothed in sackcloth
these are the two olive trees and the
two lambs standing before the god of the
earth
if anyone wants to harm them fire
proceeds out of his mouth
and devours their enemies that if anyone
wants to harm them he must be killed
they have power to shut up heaven that
rain doesn't fall
and so forth when they finish their
testimony the beast that ascends out of
the bottomless pit will make war against
them overcome them and kill them their
dead bodies will lie in the great city
which is spiritually is sodom and egypt
there where our lord was crucified so
first who are
the two witnesses of revelation 11.
um you remember what jesus said in john
chapter 5 verse 39
he said
you search the scriptures and in them
you think you have eternal life but they
are they that testify of me so jesus
helps us the word testify is maturia
which is the word witness so jesus said
the scriptures are the witness of him
the old testament and new testament then
would be the two witnesses
these two witnesses have the power to
shut up heaven what does that mean so it
doesn't rain in other words they have
prophetic power there's prophetic power
in the bible where the bible has made
various prophecies what does it mean
these two witnesses uh clothed in
sackcloth for a hundred uh for two 1260
days
the bible teaches in daniel chapter
seven it talks about a time times and
half a time talks about in revelation 42
months talks about 1260 days this is the
great period of the dark ages
538-1798 so the two witnesses the old
and new testament prophesied in
sackcloth during that time
church powers dominated the word of god
was in sackcloth at the end of that time
what happens the bible teaches
that these two witnesses would rise up
again and proclaim god's power at the
end of the
18th century
1798 and on with his great mission
movement that's where the missionaries
began to the great bible translation
movement and so
the two witnesses are the old and new
testament what does it mean they're in
the streets of sodom and egypt egypt
represents atheism sodom represents
immorality and what does it mean three
and a half years there in the streets
1795 to 1798 at the end of the dark ages
the french revolution took place the
bibles were burned and destroyed and
sodom
france at that time became atheistic
like egypt it became immoral at that
time and
at the end of that time what happened
these two witnesses rise up to proclaim
god's word and the french revolution is
over it's all part of the sequence of
prophecy now if you have questions about
that and i've gone over this really
quickly if you have questions about that
go to hope lives 365 bible study dot com
we have bible studies on daniel bible
studies and revelation that will give a
much more complete answer to that
question matt